okay,
yes, completely in time, the countdown
is running, welcome
here on the early morning for Berlin, it's a
nice thing for everyone to have found
it, it's about the future of
food, it's about food hack and
holistic sustainability and it's
about the cooperation between the
foodcampus Berlin and the  ZEW and Thilo
can briefly introduce themselves,
but Thiele and I share a love
of good food, one might say, and of
good wine, bracket by bracket, and
we are united by the realization that we
have to get off our asses and the
planetary boundaries are dramatically
stressed
Food has a big
impact and we have to act and
should act. I thought it was really nice to
come in here this morning and
see the dinosaur downstairs. I could
n't really imagine beforehand
that a room like that would fit with a
dinosaur Velcro and  the topic of future food
but of course it fits
together perfectly. Everyone who has watched the film Don't Look
knows that it was about my
meteorite impact, symbolic of
climate change, which is being denied and I.
Food has this big impact
or, to put it simply, the battle for
a sustainable future  is
won or lost on the plate and
that is because we
can of course make eating decisions several times a day
and that is much easier than if we had
mobility now. We buy a
new car every few years if at all and
we can make the eating decision
every day  several times and we
can basically make this change
cost- and effort-neutral, which
also makes the food sector
super exciting.
Most people in this room
probably know that three foods
are responsible for 30 percent of greenhouse gases and
70% of biodiversity losses. That's
highly dramatic
and  There are natural approaches to solutions
who were just there at breakfast,
we had a plant based breakfast,
that's one direction, there is the
so-called planetary health style that
starts at the planetary boundaries and there
is a super exciting study that has
only been around for two or three weeks  old there was
an investigation into what effects
planetary health has, it's
essentially about reducing animal
components on our plates, it
goes to the reduction of foodways governed to the
greening of agriculture, what
effects does that have on agriculture
if we all look for planetary
health  at would feed in
Germany and it came out that
so much space would be freed up here
that we
could feed an additional 70 million people, i.e. the 80
we have plus 70 and I think that's
a very strong number that simply shows
that we have incredible potential  It's possible
to raise this and that's why
we have to tackle it, let's do it, I would
say and and today we have two
start-ups that come on stage after a short input
from both of us:
Tanja from Perfect and Wiki from formo, who
both have different approaches to this  We
have the topic of new food and
would introduce ourselves here later and initially
it's about two places because we
are convinced that we need
two places for this change that we need
and I see these two places as
your
house on future Food and the food Campus
Berlin  As a transformation accelerator so
that we can step on the gas and
create the nutrition walls, you can
briefly introduce yourself and then I'll start with
the charts to the food campus and then you
to Zurich
Name I'm socialized as a farmer
and have been doing research in Wädenswil at
the university there for 25 years  and
work and I'm very happy that
a bridge
has now been created through you to Berlin
and how the big challenges
where you
can really lose your joy can be tackled together very
well. I don't think I've even
introduced myself yet, I'm Jörg Reuter something like that
like head of food Campus Berlin and
together with my team here
from the Art Project Nation nutrition,
we have developed the content over the
last
year and a half and hope to be
able to start construction soon and I
would now briefly show you a few charts
why and how we create this place
and what we hope to achieve from it here is
the mission I have already
touched on that the ecological limits of
our planet have been exceeded and
the food industry is part
of the problem but it can also be part of the
solution and see you  as food
Campus Berlin as a place of solutions,
we don't want to accuse, there is a lot of
trouble, but we want to motivate people
to find solutions and we see these
solutions
holistically and from different
perspectives, so there is not just one
right way but there are
many right ways and  Our wish is
that the very different
disciplines and currents come together at the food campus
and thus
accelerate transformation together
and the problem here is the planetary
boundaries. Maybe some people know the
model, I like it a lot from
Rockström, among others, the model
where it's about us  We talk
a lot about the climate crisis, and rightly so,
but we also have other problems
such as
biodiversity loss and other
problem areas and you can see from
the red fields that many are well
beyond the limits of what the
planet can actually regulate itself
and that's where we are too  When it comes to the
topic of regeneration,
we have to focus on the food sector,
so we have the responsibility
to make these processes regenerative so that
we can get things back to good
or at least stop the negative
effects. At the food campus we
have defined four strategic fields, which is
natural once we  from planetary
health that come from then it's very
much about reducing animal
components on our plates, which is
why the topic of
new protein is up here, we also have the
two start-ups like Tanja from
plant based have something to say about it  will
and wiki from the area of
precision fermentation what will
say about it it is of course all these things help
to change our eating habits and
briefly to give a number we have to
reduce our consumption of animal foods by approximately 75%
the second topic if  If I
go around to the right, that's sustainable food service
or retail. Like the
gatekeepers in the market, we have everything we eat
either bought in the supermarket or
eaten somewhere in the restaurant or in the canteen, which means it's a
whole  important players because what the
canteen doesn't offer we ca
n't eat and what isn't in the
supermarket we can't
eat either and that's why we want to
take them with us from the start and in the next few
years we see a particularly big
leverage in the area of ​​food service  everything
that concerns except home catering because
of course new recipes can also be well
placed below the topic of
organic transformation I think
Cem Özdemir's goal of 30% organic farming is
completely right in Germany, that's
exactly in the right direction of course
we also have to think about what we
With the 70% who otherwise do agriculture,
they have to be ecologized overall,
but the issue of building organic land and the supply
channel is extremely important and we,
as Food Campus Berlin, also see ourselves as a place
where we want to bring people together and
also want to bring the new protein movement
together with the organic farming movement
to say you can't
ecologize your processes as a whole if
you think about things and I learned the fourth field
from Tilo, very cool
foodshain architecture. This is
about us really
looking at things holistically and then we
talk a lot about proteins that
somehow  It's totally sexy to talk about proteins,
even if we don't actually
have protein supply problems, but it
symbolizes the topic of new food and
what's very important I learned from Thilo
allstreams a mainstream so we
have to look at the side streams in
food production  But can we go
into it in more detail later in the discussion? These are our
four fields.
We're trying to say the
holistic approach at the food-campus
campus,
of course we're talking about future
days and digital, but we're talking about
food and food is  always think about the
emotional that is much more than
reason if we only ate a sensible
diet then we could
solve the problems 1 in 60 all of them we
don't eat means much more that is
cultural background habit
reward community and so on that's
why this is for us  The
area of ​​tension between future food and
tradition is very important and we
also see the topic of culinary art
cooking food crafts at the food campus, that is
very important to connect the two things
and the other axis is the problems
that we have to solve are global so
planetary hearts are a global topic
but  We have seen in the last few years of
multiple crises that we
also have to deal with resilient regional
value chains,
so here is the holistic approach, we
are very grateful, we have
n't built anything yet, so
I get emails every week so we can talk to each other
Meeting at the Food Campus and
drinking coffee together, that would be very
unromantic if you went there today, it
's a really big piece of land and
there's just dirt and old
concrete that has to go and this huge
old construction crane that can be seen here in the
picture is a historical one  Architectural monument too
but the press takes
the topic incredibly well wherever we see it
obviously needs places like
we do in Berlin and Zurich
and so that people can come
together
and here you can see it again in all its
glory before I  Tilo
would like to briefly explain to you what
we are doing, so this is the
structure that we are
going to build in the Schöneberg Tempelhof district. Building permits
are in place. We hope that we
might be able to complete
the construction pit this year, but it should be in spring at the latest,
so in February
It's about to start and that's 40,000
square meters of floor space, which is
a lot, so if you
stand on the property today and under this
crane, you were there when we stood under the
crane, then you start to
think WoW, something is going to be very big here
We do and we are really happy
that we already have an incredible run of
companies on this food
campus, so down there these two
lower levels that are optically broken through by this old
rail where the crane is pushed back and forth,
that's 10,000 alone
Square meters together and yesterday
a colleague wrote to me that we
only have 50 square meters left,
the rest is basically already filled.
Companies, it works
great, so there is this need
and these are companies from really
international companies with
billions in sales to small
startups  we
'll be working together on the future here so much about the
food campus Berlin as a place and now
I'll give you the floor Tilo what are you doing
in Switzerland
thank you very much dear Jörg
what exactly do we need very briefly everywhere
yes that's
how much time we have to have I greet you
warmly  from our institute director
Michael Kleiner, who
cannot be with us today due to a bereavement, we are
thinking of you and your family Michael,
he has worked on the topic with us over the past few years,
of course he has
also
pushed our department head forward so far with ursilver
that we are now  we show here in
rendering but the building is already there
next year we will move into it
then we will also show live pictures you
are of course very welcome there
in Wädenswil on Lake Zurich I come from
the Zurich University of Applied
Sciences we are the largest
multi-disciplinary university of applied sciences in
Switzerland  So we're in between in this
wonderful Zurich as a university location
between ETH University and business. Yes,
we've also looked at key areas.
One of them is tainable
packaging,
the other is rejenitive food processing.
I can tell you more about that in a moment
and fermentation and
biotransformation,
yes that will be a place  be where we
try, together with our
partners in Berlin and around the
world, to let the new into the food world
because we need the
new to tackle the big challenges.
I could come to Berlin
without
I'm a big fan of Alexander von
Humboldt  Mention yes, he
formulated the web of life and
very early on he illustrated the relationships
and influences that prevail globally
also wonderfully
with drawings where it was about
climate zones and corresponding
biodiversity,
regenerative food production, that
is the focus this morning Jörg you  You
've already mentioned that, we were
inspired by Heidegger, who
said that architecture is so
fundamental for people
For architecture,
this applies in particular to the way
we grow food, the raw materials
for it, how we process it, how we
consume it, how we prepare it,
how we discuss it with each other -
all of this is necessary to
understand the system,
now you already have it  I've heard the
term
re-generation several times,
I didn't write it that way, no typo,
systemability, yes, I can only say I
want to stay the way I am when I am,
when I have a condition that is
worth preserving. Unfortunately, we have had
so much in the last 100 years
wreaked havoc on the planet that we
simply stay as we are and
make savings and perhaps
operate circularly.
We have to go one
step further and that would be
the regenerative step we have
formulated Region Ration is the new
system ability
that is what it means there  Where something has been destroyed
where we can, yes, humans
can't do everything, but science
can help
to repair and prepare in a targeted manner
so that resilience
becomes possible again,
then we can protect and survive what
we have and
and certainly these considerations are
circular  Economics and so on very very
helpful yes we just have to
go one step further networks where alone wo
n't be enough we need one
more step it's not just about
survival but it's also about
thriving on this planet and
not just by us but by  As
many creatures as possible otherwise
we're like the dinosaurs down there. There's
probably nothing
left that we can put in a museum.
I come
from the farm, so to speak. Our little
farm in the Rheingau is socialized.
That was subsistence farming
start to
develop something like acronomy,
develop language and
live and use the planet more and more
in the last 100 years, we have
developed such strong exploitation processes through industrialization that has
just led to this over-exploitation
and now we have to take this step with
the  Regeneration continues because
sustainability alone is unfortunately no longer
enough,
the planetary boundaries and the
development of the world's population, this is something that is
ubiquitous to all of us today.
Effects on the climate.
We no longer need
to look at biodiversity.
Four things are
particularly important for food. They all know it.
Is the food healthy?  does it come from
how was it produced but what has emerged in
the last 10 to 15 years in particular
are the ethical
questions yes it hurts me my family
other people
animals animal health animal welfare has
become a huge issue and the environment and
for some people even the
sequence is different here
If you have a pet, you know exactly
how important it is and how it belongs
to the family and accordingly
we have to clearly
face the fact that a strong driver of the
vegan movement also comes from this environment.
Things have to be rethought and  be
changed because this
over-exploitation has occurred. Keyword:
factory farming, no one can
approve of it if anyone has ever experienced it
and the distributed responsibility across chains is also a problem
if we delegate all of this to
individual links in the chain and no one has
overall responsibility  then
such problems of intensive
overuse of biological systems arise,
which is why we suggest that we consider it as a
network in order to overcome precisely
these challenges with the chain
and the distributed
delegated
responsibility and to
share them so that the values ​​we are talking about
are more respected overall
In the context of trusted
food, this can be achieved through transparency. There
are a lot of
initiatives that are running in this environment.
We have also
started various projects. One project that we are
very busy with is cocoa
and the first thing that needs to be created is data
that is both social  such as
environmental influences as well as the
ingredient side, jörg
said it Food that doesn't taste good
that won't be successful so
data is generated in order to be
able to determine that precisely and also to be
able to differentiate from one another in another
project,
for example coffee, this data is then used
via a  Print anization is
practically unchangeable and
made available via a blockchain so that
you can actually use the data that
is stored there with confidence.
A small project that I
would like to show you what we mean by regeneration.
This is one of the first panels that were
manufactured in this way in the world
a cell culture chocolate yes, we
are firmly convinced that the topic of
cell cultures is not only relevant in the area of
meat and fish but
is also particularly relevant for plant cell cultures.
We were pioneers in 2005 with the
production of the first wine in a
bioreactor, i.e. from cell cultures, not
from the  Grape but
Müller-Thurgau the grape variety was bred by the
founding director of our
Wädenswil research institution on the
grape variety and
many years later we
propagated cell materials from this dream and in the reactor, which resulted in
the first food in a reactor
that was not produced in the field
came later  then you all know that in 2013
the development with the first burger
that came out of the tank in 2015 we started with
this
chocolate project we are
convinced that advantages
can be used here because the
nutrients for the cells can be
produced regionally and regeneratively biologically
and that in  In a tank very close to
consumption,
plant cell cultures
can be produced based on the example of breweries, which
can fill a crucial gap. They will
not replace everything. We are
not making the farmers superfluous. We know
the reality. In the various
growing regions today, the climate has
changed so much that no  Yield
is also possible through genetically modified
plants that are drought-resistant,
it is no longer possible
to grow them in certain regions because
water no longer comes from the sky and that is why
we see this platform as an
example project. There is a question,
please,
yes,
so these products are not in the
Traffic, that's a big
challenge.
We have the novel food regulation in
Europe and accordingly we have to
invest a few years to even get
approval. I have the chocolate
here, but if you
try it I'll have a problem, so
I would try to prevent that, yes
Because it is not a food that you
can enjoy today, please
if you work properly for five years in
Europe and
now and on the market
what percentage of VAT should be
taken, very gardening as well as important,
so these are a lot of political
questions that we don't have today  can answer
the question and play it
out when everyone is on the podium very
well. I am firmly convinced that
we will have a significant contribution to
cell culture technology both in the
plant and animal sector. I
assume that the plants
are faster because of that  In terms of the process, the whole thing
seems to be more scalable and is more cost-effective.
A big barrier is
approval, but let's get to that later.
So we have
developed technologies, these are the two pioneers
who are not here today either, Dieter
and Regina Eibl, they really have in the
pharmaceutical sector as well as in the human sector  - area has a
lot of experience with cell cultures and we
have now taken up this topic.
Chocolate is an example project, yes,
this can also be extended to other areas
and if you
want to search for it on the Internet you can also find
illustrative films to see
the whole thing happening down here  You can
also see the cells, yes it is the cell,
so it has no consciousness.
Let's assume that it doesn't matter whether
it feeds itself in the plant or
in the reactor and
is supplied with nutrients. That takes 21 days and we
We got the first
cells from Puerto Rico in 2015.
Of course we respect the
Nagoja protocol. The farmers should
get something in return if this is
used commercially in other states. That's
no question for us. We want them to be
able to continue agroforis cultures there under decent conditions  where this
is at all possible climatically,
this development
means that we can achieve 10, 15 perhaps 20
harvests per year, whereas
in a natural environment it can only achieve two.
People are often arrogant and think
they can control cultivation systems in the open field
through pesticides through
synthetic fertilizers and so on  But that
's limited, we have more of a
chance of doing something in a reactor. In the
end, only Maja Lattner is the
head of our course of study for our new
course of study. That's what we
contribute, yes research and education in this
context. This is about
ortepreneurship, people who
want and need to change something so that we can
get on the right track, thank you very much Thilo,
impressive thank you,
I thought it was really nice to see how
everyone got restless when the chocolate
was held up. I wasn't
quite sure whether that had to do with I want to
try it now or  With the topic of
cell culture, I think there's a
lot of fascination for it. Everyone
has to be
patient for a few years until we
can officially try it, but
I think it's very nice and
if we do it now, you can
actually move forward  come
Tanja Wiki I'll bridge the gap until you're at the
front so maybe you both go to
the middle and Thilo and I to the
edge, we have this exhibit at the bottom
right when you come in, the
common area of ​​the ZAW and the
food Campus Berlin and my colleague
and colleagues, we reported a bit this morning
about the experiences from the
first day and it is really
impressive that we see that the
adults approach the topics rather conservatively,
rather skeptically and the
children are very, very open to it, so
that would have been the case in this drama  That's not what
I expected and I'm looking forward to what
the next few days will bring. I'm
happy for everyone who hasn't seen it yet to go
down and look at the
stands and join in.
From now on we'll continue with the
panel discussion here. I'm happy
I'm very happy that you're both here Wiki
and Tanja and maybe you'll
first introduce yourself plus a
quick look at what your
business actually is and why you think you
can ride the world with it and I'll just
get my stuff here but  Quiet to
Vicky, yes, I'm glad that I
can be here today, I come from formo formo is
vegan cheese but animal-free, that means
completely different than we know vegan cheese
today in the sense that
we take the cow out of the equation
and introduce help and bacteria  like
in the city, for example, they
produce alcohol and milk proteins, which means we
have a lot of little mini-curies in a
bioreactor that then
produce these milk proteins for us, which we
then further process into cheese
as we know it today, which means that
's where we have these proteins  It's a
very classic process and I've been
here for half a year now.
Previously, it was relatively clearly
geared towards investors and with me and
my staff, who have now
started there, we are entering into the discourse
with consumers with you and the world
even more strongly than before and must
Of course, find out how do we make
the topic easily accessible, how do
we reach out to society and of course it is
relatively clear to us that Jan
Sepp is very open to the topic, but of course we also
have to reach out to the older generation, they are part
of it and
of course we try to do that
make the whole thing easy to understand,
very approachable and also honest with what
we do exactly,
thank you Tanja, I love the
idea of ​​mini cows in the Reaktor
Wiki, great, I'm Tanja, I'm
fudi at heart, I'm tecky and a
full screen entrepreneur, I'm a
few years ago  Years ago I got very deeply involved in the system
of our food production
as a vegetarian and when
I simply saw the
incredibly high environmental costs
associated with chicken eggs in particular, i.e. the
mass production of animal eggs,
I simply couldn't see it anymore
and developed this idea
because I simply  I've seen, we
talk so much about the future of food. We
can now order
a
cappuccino with cow's milk or with
non-cow's milk in a café as a matter of course. When it comes to the burger, we can
choose between a cow patty, a
beef patty or a patty
that doesn't contain any animal and  hey,
the chicken egg is simply the world's
most popular animal protein and this
idea that it must be possible to make an egg without a chicken
stuck with me a few years ago. I
then discussed it with a
long-time companion of mine, Gary
Lynn, who himself is an influence  Investor has
long had the goal of banning animals
from the human food chain
and we have joined forces with Bernd
Becker. Bernd is the
former head of research and
development at Rügenwalder
Mühle who, as you
probably know, has one or two
best-selling vegan products here
ham picker and co who simply
know exactly what is needed for products to
inspire the masses because that is
exactly the condition, as you
just said, that consumers
understand and move in order to
simply build a sustainable
food system here with
perfection  as I said egg without
chicken plant based on peas
great thank you very much heart tried below
whoever was there at breakfast has already
eaten the crepes
okay otherwise maybe you're lucky and
there are a few more things below to
try a little anecdote in between
was at the weekend or last week
on vacation in Warnemünde in a hotel
with a buffet and there was the usual cold
cuts in the morning, which is what you
know and then it was separated by a few
lettuce leaves and then there was
vegan cheese and vegan sausage and
I only ever saw the older
people  They just
walked along the buffet and
took away everything, including the vegan
stuff. That's also a possibility
that they could just integrate them quietly,
but I didn't dare ask
if they had noticed what they
had actually just eaten
to you three actually,
we now have two different
approaches here, one is
plant-based, for you the topic of
precision fermentation and now
food-tech is one and you have
already touched on some of it, but what are
the
decisive success factors from your point of view  So that the
products fly with the consumer and
with the consumer,
I like to quote Bernd, who
has a very clear opinion and that it
simply has to taste really good and
that is actually our
belief, and of
course that's who we are in first and foremost
The simplicity of creating change on the
plate has
allowed it to start in the first place, in the end it
just has to taste really good at the end of the day and it
simply shouldn't mean any
compromise at all in terms of taste in terms of
functionality and so on
because the hurdle ultimately only concerns the aspect
of  Sustainability, which is of course part of
our purpose, is to put it at the forefront. In
our experience and
conviction, this is simply far too
far away to really create mass market
relevance. In
fact, we just agree, basically
taste, texture but also
price are unfortunately hygiene factors, which means
we simply have to
keep up with conventional products and
then in the next step
the sustainability factors will
be such a competitive advantage, so
we are not there yet
but we will get there that
conventional products will have problems
keeping up and I am
firmly convinced of that  that companies
like us can honestly go to market
with production processes and
which conventional producer
today likes to show what life is really like on the farm -
we can no longer see the reality when
you look at the top ten
cheese brands for protein  That's exactly
where every marketing measure is, of course, looking
for a green meadow with the
happy couple that I'm walking next to,
feeding the cheese and
a happy cow grazing in the background.
The reality is that 96% of
animal husbandry in Germany is
industrial, which means four percent
actually remain above that  See the meadow
and this sad reality
at some point you won't be
able to hide it anymore.
By the way, if you have the stamina, today I'm going to
advertise our next
session at 6 p.m. There will be a lot of people and
I also drove over. I'm currently
talking about animals
and futtech  about molecular upcycling and
why cows on romantic
mountain meadows will still be needed in the future
because it's just these with the four
percent that has to
be what it is. Thilo asked you the question as you
are all three food heck experts but
what is it?  Because it's more difficult to get the taste
into the products
or the texture
and what is more important for
success or is there no
gradation? I would like to go back a little
but what was just
said seems very
much to me  In my opinion, it is important that we are currently in the
phase where we are
dealing with like products
lookalike taste the like and that is
exactly what you said. The
next stage will be that you can use
them as your own products as
independent products  no longer
compares it with anything else, but rather
that the product is perceived
in a
new way, both sensorily and in terms of impact. Many
products that are on the market today
already meet the texture
requirements excellently. Yes, we also have a
Zurich state startup here that is from the ETH
Does that also come
from plants? You said it, yes it
is offered on the doorstep here and we
had a Zurich Geschnetzelte on the opening evening
that is really the
Holy Grail yes that and
that was
plant-based so
texture is taken care of from my point of view yes
for different areas and the
taste  There are already very,
very good
ways to
bring that in. I mean, I do
n't want to get too scientific, but
of course these other
structures also absorb aromatic substances in a
different way and anyone who
has ever cooked with them will quickly
notice that this is not the case  It
's that simple, so
at the moment you still need a little more
science and understanding and if
you want to deal with what I would say is a rather
unprocessed product
and then want to cook with it, that does
n't apply to your products, but for
example for these
Meat substitute products that they are
planning are good if they want to
do the same thing if the manufacturers have it very well under control, you are still
required at the beginning, okay, exciting
point. So I would also like to
open it now if you
have any questions, you have these  Hand up or
question mark then I would like to
interact here. I would immediately
go to the political level which has already been touched on as a question, but now you have
made me curious here. I was just
wondering whether we are
changing  of food in the
transformation of the world also has an
impact on kitchen technology,
which will change or are we doing it
with the same things? I think
the basic processes will remain the same or
similar, but the understanding of
the raw material will be different
because the raw materials are different  but it
stays in the same pots found that
remains that of okay okay
but also you look at the the
bioreactors the households know no
not that not but who knows so
everything is possible everyone will make
their own cows at some point with their own kind
in the kitchen, yes,
I still find that exciting, so
I'm still thinking ahead, I have two
pubescent children and I
always dream of the dishwasher that
loads and unloads itself, but
in between, so to speak, let
's go to the political level,
but gladly if so  now questions are
towel
very good baker sunshine and I
see you crazy so you have to
organize yourself a bit we
see here almost only glaring light yes
thank you very much Stefan Becker sunshine
global foot collecting I wanted to ask about the
topic of formo the discussion on the one
hand was like  that the summary
the cows
and then on the other side
discussion but we still have to keep four percent
on the alpine pastures what will
the balance look like in the future we do
n't want to abolish the Turks or
animal husbandry altogether
it plays an important role like  What is
the balance between
fermented products, cell cultures and
so on and the preservation of the
cultural landscape, which we also
have to consider? Yes,
that's of course a very
interesting discussion or conversation,
I would actually say so because of
course our goal is not to abolish it,
but of course it's about that  to
look at where is the healthy balance, on the
one hand for the animal but of course also for the
environment and also for us because in the
end there is a lot of talk today
about natural and not natural if
you look at the animals today then there
is nothing natural about it at all
and I  I would then be more likely
to say
where is the attitude of the cow of course
and can you combine it? I see
the classic cheesemaker as a
part of our process but of course
also the small one who still has a cheese factory
and works directly with the farmer
will
still exist in the future, it will
probably be something like what people
say today: I can buy meat from a
big pack at Lidl for
90 cents a chicken breast
or I can buy it directly from the farmer
or from the dealer in Berlin  Those who
buy the meat where I know the
cooking isn't that bad so you
can understand these processes exactly
and I think
transparency says that's a really big
key and the two things will
work very well side by side
but the broad mass market is the one
we're actually targeting
I would like to add a number to that, the
planetary health says roughly we
have to reduce the animal components here in Germany by 75
percent,
that means yes, that
's a milkmaid rule, we can
say it we need 75% fewer animals
overall
In the meat sector alone, we are talking
about a market of 40
billion euros in Germany, of which
75% are 30 billion in
transformation, so it is an extremely
interesting market what will happen there
and
in my view only one in four animals will remain in the
future  If we
take the planetary boundaries seriously and
we then also have to think about how
we keep these remaining animals, but
there were even more questions in the audience,
we now have to use the greyhound principle,
please, so thank you for the lecture  I
have very little idea about it and I
would really like to hear a few key words about
how it is produced, what does it
mean here in the reactor, what does 13
harvests mean and how energy-intensive is that, thanks? Yes,
you have to
imagine it like a classic
beer brewery, like a brewhouse  When I
see a brewhouse I see a
media kitchen, yes, and that's what goes
into the tanks. We've just
completed the first studies where we're
using similar technologies for stirring as in the brewery. We do
n't want to run an electric stirrer for three weeks,
we're going to stir  with a
continuous chain of bubbles that brings
air into the tank via a compressor,
this saves a lot of
energy than operating it with
electric motors and yes, the
hygiene changes for plant
cell cultures are definitely
comparable to brewing beer. If you
talk to a brewer,
they will  They also report
that
lactic acid bacteria, for example,
are not wanted at all, they
want to come from culture fermentation
in most cases, which is why they have
an understanding of hygiene, but the thing with
plant cell cultures goes
a little further, that is, the
surface sealing is relatively
comparable to breweries and
so on  You just have to keep in
mind that we today see
beer as a luxury food rather than an
alcoholic or non-alcoholic
drink, but that was also more of a
substance, yes, where it came from, depending on how
strongly you let it ferment, there
is more intoxication in it  or
less, in any case, it is more
means and when you see the triumph that
beer brewing has actually made on the planet from the Fertile Crescent,
I think that is a
blueprint for cell cultures. I
also really think that they know it energetically.
You can only say exactly when you do
One factory builds it and measures it, the other one
is simulations but it looks
like it would be much more
environmentally friendly than thank you. This
was a question from the second row, yes
please white white shirt
thank you very much and when I hear there are
ports that produce milk proteins or
in general there are  Since there are a lot of products
that are being researched these days,
I always think of Chris Perkers.
No, for example, genetic scissors
or genetic engineering in general. I myself
had now now I don't have such a
big problem with it because I know, okay,
what happens, what measures will be taken,
for example  Approval has been taken but
how do you want to deal with these problems
because a typical consumer
today has a big problem with
genetic engineering? Genetic engineering is being
dragged into the media, how should I put it, and very
badly done, especially by Greenpeace, often under an
excuse that I don't now  I
can definitely understand it because from a
scientific point of view, well,
if you do it well and
control it well, then it's okay, how do
you deal with this problem, especially
when I think about this yeast, it
's guaranteed to be
genetic engineering, so that's what it does  Yeast
not just like that, yes, that
's correct, I think we can go
back to this topic a little bit once
we've tacked on the price, texture and taste,
then bring out a healthier product
that's even better for the
world and healthier for people
themselves, I actually believe
Now that might even sound a bit
shallow, but that will solve a big problem
because fear can, especially if you know it
as a very conscious German
penny-pincher, then that's
a huge point and I think
that the whole GMO issue is
just crazy crazy  We
had bad preparatory advisors back then and now,
of course, we believe that we
can communicate this much better and, above
all, we will be better at
dealing very honestly with each other and especially when you now
think about the younger generations coming up, they know that
I have something  have to change and who
are superheroes these days, we are the
modern superheroes, there are
scientists in our
laboratory and they are incredibly
kind, honest, nice people
and if you put them more in the center
and just what you do every day,
I think  Really honesty is
above all and that will also be appreciated by the
consumer. Maybe
you can, so a quick question for you
or I'm not a genetic engineering
expert at all, but don't we have to
differentiate between the
agricultural technology and the free one, i.e.
genetically modified and the free one  In
the sky, there is a
difference to what takes place in the reactor, i.e.
who is in the initial yeast cells
that are changed. There is a
difference whether we work in a controlled
media or out in the
field ultimately not when it comes to
advancing our food revolution  then it should
be possible in all areas then
we should look at what are the
best alternatives and not
categorically rule out any option.
For us, the
difference now is in communication
compared to cellular culture because there
is no
dream-out in our final product  Of course, it also makes
our communication a little easier,
but I don't mean to say that the
other is worse, on the contrary, a
famous Basel native, Bernoulli, wrote an article
about risk and opportunity management in
1782, please let me know if the
year figures weren't exact, but
everything where there are risks are  There are also
opportunities and here I think, by the way,
that the cell cultures that we
have in place are not genetically
modified for other applications,
we will need that, it's all about
responsibility, but I would like to offer you another
thought construct for the
last 100 years  Using
the planet four, we burn a
large part of the fossil reserves that have
been created over 40 billion years or so
and are conducting a huge experiment,
yes, we are warming this planet
with all the effects and and what does
the responsibility look like
if someone comes tomorrow  and
says we do geo engineering,
somehow bring school advantages into the stratosphere,
aerosols to
cool down the polar caps again and so
on, then everyone would scream and
say how can you even because you do
n't know the consequences, yes, that's true,
I wouldn't be in favor of it either  To
just do it like that, you
first have to seriously research it like you
did it and then maybe that will give us
the time we need to
become a bit more sensible overall. It takes a concept like
maybe the global citizen
and  and that Guardians of the
unborn needs this suitability for grandchildren and there
must be no means that
can be responsible with the risks can
be excluded from my point of view otherwise it is too
late okay strong statement from several
actually just a win and that's why
I wanted to raise my voice for it
because we  We talk a lot here about
the future of food and the legumes
are not represented anywhere because
they are probably more difficult
to bring to our kitchens at the moment
and are not that profitable either, but
Tanja, you can say something, you are
basically guardians of the legumes
here absolutely  That's why Marisa, my heart
jumps, thank you very much for this lance.
In fact, legumes are exactly the
best way to get change started on your
plates today,
yes, because that's exactly the question
we asked ourselves at Perfect
to see what it is  best
technology for building eggs without chicken, which
means no compromises, lazy compromises in taste, texture, functionality and so on,
and which also has the potential
to run with the shortest possible ingredient lists, yes, because we
have just made a big case
for the topic of sensory technology  broken and that's true,
we simply do
n't lie to our tongues, that is, these
organoleptic properties that
emanate from the food, the taste, the
smell, this mouthfeel, i.e. this
bite into a fresh scrambled egg,
for example, with this unique
taste explosion, that simply should
n't be produced at any price,
yes because  We simply cannot
use methylcellulose and other non-
undesirable ingredients here and so
the question arises again when we
move back to the legumes and say
what raw materials do we already have available today
that have protein, fat and
all the basic requirements in terms of functionality  to get
very close or even equivalent or
even above performing to the animal
product and what can
ideally be produced locally
yes, there are of course excellent beans in the tropics,
mung beans and so
on, which, however, then come with an
ecological footprint  That's
why it's hard to justify again
local legumes such as the
pea and the field bean, which also have
a very clear right to exist when it comes to crop rotation
because they
simply give something back to the soil and
are totally essential.
Yes, thank you, I still have them, so thank you for
your double statement too  On the subject of
legumes, I have another question
for you, Tanja. We had
the opening of the Berlin
food week with the food night two and three weeks ago and
I ate your product from PERFECTES for the first time,
so it came prepared as
scrambled eggs and I thought wow  I thought it
tasted really good and then
in the next step I
asked myself or the question for you,
you have now consciously decided on such a liquid
egg, so where the egg whites and yolks
are already together, how
perspective do you see that we are
like one  Having eggs for breakfast does it make any
sense at all, is it too complex to
recreate something like that or is that what's
next? Yes, but for us Germans
we're not allowed to take our breakfast egg. The
fun fact is that we're
actually relatively lonely all over the world.
Yes, if we just get together
Look at the entire market 1.3 million
eggs every year, that's an almost
unimaginable number. In
Germany alone, 20 billion
eggs are consumed every year. You have to
imagine that's over 240 per
person and half of them go into
egg dishes
At the beginning we looked at the market completely
pragmatically because we were
individually concerned with the question of which
application could we use to
achieve the greatest leverage as quickly as possible and here
we are simply with the whole egg and the whisked
egg, which comprises half of the entire market for
all forms of application
and then again  Looking at the egg dishes in the area,
scrambled eggs and
selected baking applications, I just want to
say that for us it is the beginning goal,
of course,
that we gradually replace egg applications for
egg applications and there will
always be consumers who
want to do without their breakfast  and it's also
fantastic to see that other
research teams are also working on a whole egg
with two phases. Now
it's all about the path to
price parity. Eggs are the cheapest.
Eggs are the cheapest animal
protein, which is offered far too cheaply
In the context of
affordability against the background of
access, we can't ignore that,
yes, and we're looking at
the forms of application that simply
offer us shortcuts, okay, what's
exciting, now that's
already crystallizing, so I can see the questions
straight away
Both are very self-confidently
aimed at the mass markets. I find that
very exciting and also important to say that
we want to make big changes and not
smaller ones that are already occupied. Please,
I think we were here for the first time. Yes,
exactly as I said, everything is fine. I
have a question about the preparation
In general, because I'm noticing more and
more, especially in my circle of friends and so on,
that people
are on the go more and more, eating more and more
prepared things and how do
these products fit in, so then you tend to follow
the trend so at some point everything
is prepared because that's just what I do
too  I see that the knowledge of
cooking is being lost a bit, so when
I teach 25-year-olds in the shared apartment
how to cook pasta or
prepare it, then I think so, yes, then
that was also mentioned,
it might be more difficult then
the ones at home too  Preparing these
new products is perhaps
something in the long term that you say
okay, at some point you just don't cook
yourself anymore or is that still an
important part and you're trying to
position these new products as well?
I'll just start, we do
n't have a product yet  the market, that's why
I'll hand it over to Tanja. I think
it's a very interesting
development that you're talking about,
but there is certainly a counter-development.
Fortunately, I think you could
try to introduce HelloFresh to cooking after the
25-year-old, that's why
It certainly won't go away that
a lot of people are cooking and maybe
for those 25-year-olds who are still
studying and are just starting a job and
everything is just getting over their heads, they
will eventually get to the point
that they cook more, but
ideally you cover both  and I
think that's just the point.
I would now actually hand it over to Tanja,
who has just mentioned the application.
You just have to look very clearly at where
you have the greatest leverage. That's where you
start and then you'll certainly work your way
into the further processing
Moving products further, there
is actually a
parallel movement on the market, so
one thing is that I'm now of course looking
very much with an iPhone at
this as a staple food, very
similar to milk, simply a very, very
strong application in households and
also in the catering industry  so on and so on
and eggs, like milk, are
simply incredibly deeply anchored in the
European
culture of enjoyment. That means there
are simply pleasure
rituals that have been developed over generations and the
ultimate aim here is that we
create as little friction as possible with animal-free products. Yes, that we do  Let us
integrate ourselves into this everyday life as smoothly as possible, that we do
n't come in different formats,
that we don't bring any deviations in
the preparations in order to
simply consistently reduce the hurdle
and then again we have
this development in the convenience food
area that you  You have just mentioned the fact that
not only the
hn consumers have their own households
but also the guests because there are
completely different pain points, so there is a
lack of staff, there is a lack of
cooks everywhere, which means that completely
new food concepts are needed when it comes to shelf
life  in terms of naturalness in terms of
shortened forms of preparation to
cover that with to give a very
concrete example of this whole
away from home area i.e. and
the hotels restaurants café but also
the logistics of what we get on the train
in the board bistro what we go to
Airports in the launches and so on
all have huge
problems preparing the food
and we can ultimately
offer a great shortcut with alternatives
because, for example, an egg made from peas
is stable in the pan so it doesn't turn gray, it does
n't get watered down, it doesn't dry
out and there  Let's then get into the very
exciting economic case of
saying what else do we have
to attach sustainability and taste to what
then a
willingness to pay is okay,
exciting, that basically means that a
certain degree of superiority of the
substitute products over classic products
you wanted to ask again about it, okay
Then we have now
had at least two three more questions. Yes,
hello, I'm
actually interested in what kind of nutrient, what the
basis of the nutrient solution for the
microorganisms is and what other substances
can be used.
Would you like to start? Yes, actually
what other substances are certainly
exciting  working with molasses right now,
but a lot will be possible in the future
and ideally we
would get there at some point, especially
if you now think about where to put such
a bio-reactor, that should not
only happen in Europe but also
internationally  For
example, you can use grass yourself, which
is of course a thing of the future, but you
can work with a lot of things,
but it is of course part of very intensive
research and you have to say very clearly
that this is an incredibly new
area that is also relatively in its infancy  That
means a lot can happen,
but you probably know it
better, so I mean, first of all,
a cow is actually a living
bioreactor, with the systems and also
with the microorganisms in us, by the way,
we have our microbiome with us
Our best possible
nutrients are also to be included, others are
not, yes, a ruminant like this is really superior to us
in some places,
but to specifically address the question,
carbohydrates, sugar, we need
amino acids, proteins, yes, that is an
important factor, minerals, and then
and now we get into
problem areas  In plant
cell cultures today there are also
phytohormones, these are signal substances
that are represented and then added. There
will be other ways in the future
and that means I no
longer have to use chemically represented hormones
and in animal
cultures it is also the case that
some of them are there  the growth factors are
obtained from Sölden from calves,
that's not so nice then there is the
next step where
these
co-factors are also produced through genetic changes
in the bioreactor and that is again
an approval problem in the EU, yes
if you do  The path then goes and and you no
longer have to kill calves for it
then you have the walking technique problem,
I say and I agree with you completely,
yes, in terms of perception, it has
reached the point where it
was at least difficult for some people and
still is  But I am also firmly
convinced that through the topic of
individual medicine and then the
next step, then individual
nutrition, we will
make progress there too and it is
wonderful what my
colleagues at the site report,
grandchild meets grandmother and grandson goes with
grandmother  The topic is completely different
because there is simply a different
socialization. If I
can briefly talk about this enzyme, we all eat it every day.
I don't know if everyone is aware of that,
so what Thilo just mentioned
is animal rennet and microbial  Rennet
if you look at the back of the cheese,
in the best case scenario it says
microbial rennet because then the cheese is
also vegetarian, otherwise it is not
vegetarian because otherwise the enzyme from the
calf's stomach is in it. I don't know who
knows that they like parmesan, the
Italians insist on it  that it is
animal if it is microbial body
is produced in the same way as our
process via precision fermentation and
that has been around for over 20 years and with
a large application worldwide with
a vector that people don't
like to hear that richer coli
mainly
shelf indicator but it  There are new
systems where this is transferred and is based on the
romy cyst revisier the real beer
or wine yeast and and I think there
will also be dairy products that are or
are there already that are very, very exciting
but just that we are stuck and that is what
I think  You can also
address it critically in a legislative trap,
with the novel food regulation
that has simply determined since
1997 that everything that had not been done before
in the food sector in Europe and
was consumed in larger quantities is
classy food and then here is what it is
actually about  In
terms of construction, it's a good measure in terms of consumer protection,
but we have to test things,
it's unbelievable and I think it would be
very, very useful if someone here
is active in politics or listens to you,
it would be very, very useful to talk
to technical experts  Experts
take a step and bring the F-SA up to
date, so in summary,
it's good that we have one on the
food regulation, that things are
examined critically, it's difficult
that
some of them are old-style methods with
which they are examined  and what else I
've probably heard from other startups,
the process should ideally take 18 months,
but in reality it's
usually at least three years and it
costs a lot of money, so
some kind of
final bureaucratization is certainly needed here  so that we can
move forward with the topics
more word more the baker
sunshine was definitely that
I see that is good because there is shade here when there
is registration in the corner there
you don't have to wave your name to see the movement
yes I wanted to
ask another question  to Tanja,
with Solar Foods there is also a
production of protein powder from
CO2 bacteria and renewable energy
and they also say or propagate
that you could make scrambled eggs from it
with the appropriate
supplements, which may then in the future
also be a substitute base material that
you can use with it  would use if they
could supplement it with this in addition to the legumes because then the
sustainability footprint
would be even higher than with legumes. Yes, the short
answer is yes, the slightly more detailed
answer is that that is exactly our goal
because for us legumes at this point in
time  The best
starting material is yes and it
is very clear to us that
in the future we will not only
remain in the area of ​​flexitarians and
go into the area of ​​beta eaters,
but also in order to really be a real
replacement product for the broad masses and
also meet the taste requirements
Texture, functionality and ultimately also
price are much, much higher and with this in
mind, we have structured our entire
R&D system in a tech-agnostic way.
That means, parallel to the non-noble food
process, we are of course also working
on alternative technologies
for raw materials, which is
always very simple for us  What is essential is what is
pragmatically the fastest
way to set a simple lever and
everything else because we have just
made the decision there are
good starting materials that are also available in the
right combination and with the
right positions technologies with
a few other substances without
methycellulose and all of that  Others
can work to get rid of the problematic substances, but we all
still have a long way to go and for that
we need better
approval timelines and
we still have a lot of homework to do in the economy, in the
food industry, in politics, in terms of
precisely this innovation
When it comes to cycles, it is very important to promote there
will be new sources of
raw materials for these products but, for
example, there are also considerations about
removing nitrogen from the air, then
we first introduce it into a new
cycle, which must also be consistent
look closely what I
find very exciting is that they all know
the fifth element,
not what Look showed better and
with the people in his film,
but the fifth element is
slime without slime, no life, yes,
and in this slime in the primordial slime
there  Bacteria have also found their home
with Hanno Drope bacteria there
is
a company that
has now been set up in China kalista you know
the British researchers
behind it who from methane with these
bacteria these bacteria have
contributed to the fact that we
can breathe our air at all  The planets
have taken the hair out of the
atmosphere and with it they
now practically produce biomass
that is now used for fish feed and
chicken feed for
pig feed and the next stage is
that you can become one. I
would like to take it up  the
discussion we just had, I
'm not so into
detail when it comes to futex things and
the event is called, I think
futact meets tourism
sustainability and I would be interested in
the discussion of all three of you  What does
the
ideal picture look like for you in the future from
agriculture
to the consumer in a kind of elevator
pitch, so what is your vision,
what will it look like for you from your
perspective, what type of
agriculture is taking place, how will it be
processed, how will it be  You want to start eating,
so basically holistic
is exactly the right term. You
just have to
understand exactly what
the individual processes are along the entire value chain
That's what's happening
now, it's not the point we've
committed ourselves to, but you find
the right partners for each individual part
who concentrate on such
points, which means you have to
look closely at where you get your
raw materials from and then also in your own
production  see what happens to
the residues or waste materials
because even if you empty a bioreactor like this, there's
still something left over, what can you
do with it yourself,
if not, we'll find partners who
can somehow do something with it
and process it further and
then from the point where we get to the
product, what exactly is
the packaging that we use and on a
small scale what in our office who
turns the light off so we are
very meticulous with us only vegan
expanded everything else is there  Not with us
and I think you have to
look at every detail and you can
have a Tanja and I were just
talking about it, of course I saw an
unhappy August, you still have
milk and a coffee
and you have to think holistically
now  The question is how much is
renunciation and how much is change,
but I think what
often
gets lost in such conversations is that we as a
company or in research
can change things, but the consumer
also has to do without,
okay
for us it works too  Clearly in
the perspective of a fully integrated
value chain, so really 360
degrees and not just on the
raw materials, the whole thing starts with a
broader look at the production
and especially the packaging
because I think the egg is a
miracle of nature, not just
nutritionally and physiologically  Functional things
also come in their own
designer packaging, yes, and that's just what
we currently use, fully
recycled pet, just taken the first
introductory guide because there's
a whole lot more that
has to happen.
Maybe my statement is a bit sobering,
I think so  We will
need various solution scenarios in order to be able to overcome the
big challenges we are
facing.
With 10 billion people, this will become a
reality. We won't be able to avoid it. We
will probably
not need all the resources for somehow and
to feed the people because if you do  If you
look at the statistics at the back, it's
always a bit behind, but if
we look at FAU, there are
now efforts from various
providers to make the data available
to show what is produced where in the world and
in what quantities and
if you then stack them on top of each other  it
's not just the protein, yes, there
are
nutritionists here too,
doctors, it's not just the protein,
the whole the whole nutrient base for
so many people,
we won't be able to do that alone in the tank or in
the meadow, yes, so I
think it's very  It's important that we
approach this holistically and understand
how the
value networks work
and how we change our thinking and
adapt. I think personally without the
ruminants, but that
will be another point tonight, it wo
n't work either, so you can
just  Says we only do plant-based wo
n't work Meat is a
very high quality protein and so
the challenges are so
diverse that I have to be honest and say
sometimes as an interested person
and researcher
I don't know how to deal with it so
I'm not
resigned  and I don't have
depression either, but I have great respect
for what's going on. For
me, that's the perfect keyword to
move on to the future. We're
here today as a
community event, Zurich meets
Berlin, and we're
already living it  Cooperation between etc and
the food campus and the two cities
and what we are specifically planning is to do a
summer school together next year on
the topic of future food planetary
health and I would be interested in it, so
it is also about taking the young people
with you and that will be the case  Part of
our cooperation is of
course research but also
training and you might have chosen us
with a little envy to go to
Switzerland ahead of us at the ZHAW also
thanks to Maya and Thilo with the new
courses but if we are now
introducing the summer school  Let's see what
your wishes would be about what young
people should be taught in such a summer school on the
subject of planetary health. I do
n't
know who would like to start, I think because you just
brought up the keyword young people.
I think that what do we need
the whole thing for?  It's relatively easy to just let it be
dealt with because we're just
Wiki you've already brought it to gensi
because we're already much more
aware of the fact that
ultimately things just can't continue in this status quo,
but if I
now look at the wishes in terms of content,
of course that's it  to put why in
the foreground and
to look at the skin very systematically.
Yes, I remember the time
when I somehow switched from fashion to food
and first of all
I delved into all the technologies
in order to understand what
works and where  are limitations where
are potentials and I have exchanged ideas with so many
people about
shortening a process like this in order to
really provide a clear view of it as an executive summary,
okay then Wiki is yours for this
round  Something would be your
expectation of the summer school on the topic of
future food. Yes, I see it a bit
similarly to Tanja. I think the
awareness is already there in the generation,
but what are the means and the
knowledge of what is happening in this area?
I just mentioned it myself  I've
been at Formo for half a year now.
Before that, I was completely
unaware of what was happening here and I am
firmly convinced that there is
a revolution here, that it will be a
food revolution, but
hardly anyone knows that yet, but a young
generation knows that and has these
possibilities  Starting a we
may see even more foundations, you have to
say that we are of course advocates
for the respective companies but
nevertheless more
competition is needed. You can tell I'm
from Berlin here, real Denglish
but I think that a
lot more needs to be explained  what
are the possibilities, what can young
people do, be it in companies
like perfect or form or to start and
build up interest in it or to
create completely new things
and that only happens if they know what
they are doing super great strong
strong statement we are in front of  of a
food revolution but too
few people know about it, I would like to thank you both very much
for the insight into your work and
the open discussion here. Maybe you'll
both be there to
discuss it, thank you very much and
now I'd like to ask
Tilo too  But it can
still stand,
I think that's good. I really have to
write it down straight away with the food
revolution. Maybe that's the
title for our summer school. I'm
now handing over the moderation to Maja,
who not only
set up this great course of study, but also  now she
will also be moderating our cooperation, thank you very much Jörg
exactly, dear guests, I am very happy,
we already had
enjoyable and inspiring moments this morning
and now we would like to get into action.
I am very pleased to be able to moderate it.
My name is Maja Ladner
I invest part of my time
as a course director at the ZHAW and
beyond that I am simply
fascinated by bringing
people together in education and making changes together
and for this next part I would like to
welcome a few more guests here - on the one hand, Professor Dr
Urs Hilber, he is the director of the
Department of Life Sciences and
Facility Management at the ZHAW.
Then
I would also like to welcome David
Hampel, he is the head of the
industrial production department at Berlin
partners.
I am making a little space and nothing.
Last but not least, Anna  Schindler Children,
she is the director of
urban development for us in the city of
Zurich
[applause]
as I was preparing for this morning
I asked myself
what kind of image comes to mind
when I think of this partnership
that is here today  manifested and
at some point I
got to the fungus with the fungus counting yes exactly
I can already see the frown I do
n't know if you know what the
purpose of the mushroom is, it's something incredibly
fascinating Mushrooming is WC is
the actual fungus it's a tissue
that weaves through our soils, we
still know far too little about it,
but it is central to
communication and the exchange of nutrients
between, for example, trees and
plants and that is exactly how I imagine
this partnership to be a
partnership that
provides a network so that
innovative ideas can thrive
Why is it so important? We have all
noticed that we cannot achieve the central
change for our food systems alone,
or only very slowly, and now
we would of course like to hear from these
partners that we have here today,
why is the partnership
so important for them and  That's why I'm
happy to hand over the floor, have we already got the micro
to US Silver? Why is this
partnership important for the ZHAW?
But I really enjoy being in Berlin and
I'm lucky that every time
I'm in Berlin something
historical happens that has nothing to
do with me, I'm just always
there and with soul is also the good
keyword, I'm a mushroom researcher
From the house and in a very earlier
life, one of my first
scientific congresses that I was
allowed to attend took place here in Berlin,
which means it didn't take place because
then there was a lot of the Wall and I was there,
that was epochal and today I'm
there too. Meier has it
I was asked to briefly say why and I don't
think I have to say anything else. They
've heard the two lectures. That's
basically all that's been said. When I came
down here this morning,
I was extremely impressed by this dinosaur.
Something went wrong historically,
climatically and today  look at the
young people there
but today is a day of joy for us
a Federal Councilor once said that there is
joy and I am really
very pleased to be here today and also
proud to be here I come from
the Zurich University of Applied
Sciences Applied Sciences
Research  and education is our life
for both research and education we
need a broad horizon,
we are motivated by our
students,
talented young people and what we
want we want to leave behind an inheritance or a
legacy
that contributes to ensuring that
our children's children have a similarly good future
or  have an equally good
basis in life as ourselves, we
would like to make a contribution to
what you heard in the first hour
and no matter what contribution, every
contribution is important. For this reason we are looking for
partners because
you are not good at research or
education alone  is only good together
and we have we are looking for partners in the
topic of future food
the concept that has already been mentioned
planetary health is one of the
most important concepts
on this earth at the moment it is about
sustainability it is about resilience it is
about regeneration and who would be here
not the best partner than the food
Campus Berlin I also like the
abbreviation FCB because it also stands for
Basel Football Club
and we are in the process of constructing an axis as ZEW
Posten Zurich Berlin these
are the three places where we find that in the
area of
food malnutrition at the moment
This is why we have also
prepared a memorandum of understanding
that today we
will sign the ZAW and the
FCB and we will thus
formalize our cooperation and the
already mentioned collective school desire of
the FCB is important to us for two reasons:
You have seen the impressive
building that is where scale will take
place. This is something that we
are not active in, we are active in the previous phase
and there will also be application of
what we need as applied
sciences.
Our part of the campus, the Future food Campus, will be there
next year  moving
into the lake in week 5 of 2024, to which you are
cordially invited, we will
open the campus and
I am extremely happy, based on the words of Adolf Hockey  I
would like to
thank all of you, the organizing committee at the food Campus Berlin and everyone who helped, for allowing me to stand here today
for the two
[applause]
the great words. I think it's a
beautiful symbol. We use the mushroom
to count and to each other
to strengthen symbioses and to work together for
a better future
and now of course we
also want to hear about your herbs, that
means very good for the FCB,
I can already see with jerseys, I
've already said a lot, you've already
heard a lot about that  I'll do it very
briefly Collaboration needs people and
skills and shared visions and
that's basically the story of
our cooperation, which started
last summer with Thilo Hühn on
LinkedIn, so if you don't
follow us on LinkedIn yet, maybe you should
or are welcome to do so  you wrote me a
message that was very philosophical.
You met Tilo. Sometimes
he is called a free
radical and I thought
that was going to be tiring. What kind of person
are they and then he
wrote me a second message,
I thought  yes, okay, then I'll answer that.
Then we met via the screen
and immediately noticed from the dialect that we were
both
raised with wine and Rüdesheimer coffee instead of mother's milk,
so we grew up very close to each other and shared the
same visions,
and from that, a cooperation was formed, so to speak, at the
speed of light
grown up then I was with you in December
and was deeply impressed that the
people from the ZAW not only talk
but are also damn competent and
I was deeply impressed by what I
saw from you and what I already
have on the subject of
food technology and
we can believe that  I'm learning a lot from you
and I'm really looking forward
to working with you, thank you very much.
Such partnerships like those that are
emerging today actually only make visible
what has been coming together under the ground for a long time
and
such partnerships are also very important beyond the visual boundaries
for
example for regions in which they
are based and that is why I would
like to hear from Anna Schindler from the
city of Zurich what does
such a partnership mean for regions
like Zurich, thank you
very much, Professor Hilber, dear
Mr. Reuter, I am pleased, I would like to thank
you  On behalf of the city of
Zurich, I would like to congratulate FCB
on this very exciting
cooperation and I am very pleased that
Zurich and Berlin
are acting together as innovation engines in this area of ​​food technology and nutritional sciences.
That is actually exactly what we do with what
we do  Here we are doing this,
we want to promote this festival Zurich with Berlin. We are here for the first time.
This festival has been around for a few
years. This is the first time we are
guests of another festival and the Berlin
Science Week and what is very important to us
is this cooperation,
bringing people together  see that people
work together and that something
concrete is created, that hasn't always been
the case up until now, but I think
it's really great and I'm also
convinced that it doesn't just need
political declarations, it
really needs the people who live
between the cities  individual
cities work together beyond the cities,
they can do research, they
can also be artistically active, but
they are the ones who really build the bridges,
especially now in the case from Zurich
to Berlin and we will
talk about sustainable nutrition. I
learned a lot about eggs earlier or  It's
not eggs that we're
talking about sustainable nutrition.
I don't think it's a coincidence - the topic is
also on our minds in Zurich  The
background
also has the course that has become active in the
field of nutrition and has only
recently presented its strategy for sustainable
nutrition and that may
sound strange but
nutrition shapes sustainable
urban development with it has space and
socially relevant questions about
food in school buildings like where it
comes from  everything from procurement to
planning transport routes for
food, it is also one of the
factors, even if it seems a bit
absurd at first glance, it
also has a lot to do with the city and
city life and at the very
end I would like to give you a
little one  Revealing the secret Our
next destination as part of Zurich
Meteo City will be
held in Kottenhagen again next year and
then we will devote ourselves entirely to
the topic of nutrition. We are
guests at the Cooking
Copenhagen Festival and it's not just
about cooking and so on  street food but
also a lot, you
probably know a lot about research in this area.
Congratulations again on this
cooperation, which I believe will now be
signed and I am happy
and I wish you all
a nice stay at Berlin
Science, especially in the context  of
Zurich with Berlin
exactly and just as exciting as the
city of Zurich can and will be, of course it is
also for Berlin or absolutely
I
wore my brand new sneakers
here with the Berlin to celebrate the day, it was said that they
were also sustainably produced
Vegan today I would have liked that it did
n't say Berlin on both sides,
but rather that
Zurich was mentioned on one side, yes, and so
at this point I would like to take this opportunity to once again extend
my heartfelt congratulations to both the
food campus Berlin and
the Zurich University  for
applied sciences I
learned a lot today. It is clear to all of us
that there are incredible global
challenges ahead and that
not only in terms of climate policy but
of course also in terms of health policy and
what the latest news or the
news of the last few days has
shown us all also brings with it security policy
aspects
So global problems and challenges
that show regional approaches to solutions here very
nicely and I would now
allow myself to say that despite the
distance between Berlin and Zurich one can speak of
a certain regionality in the
international context
and for that
I would like to congratulate you on your success
here  in Berlin with the food campus where
I think we will hear and see a lot more.
It is an
enrichment for the location because we
receive inquiries from all over the world
every day.
We receive inquiries from startups from
companies that are also
familiar with the Berlin ecosystem and that
Potential We have a test market
of around 6 million inhabitants in
Berlin and the surrounding area. I don't think that's
necessarily a disadvantage if you
want to come onto the market somewhere with new product ideas and innovations. Of course we have the
start-ups here  and we have
a high level of
openness among the people here in
the city and that's why I wish
this cooperation and the food campus every
success with everything that comes with it and I have an extreme opinion of everything I've
heard today  It's a good
feeling when we
can support business and technology development,
we're incredibly happy to do this with
our networks and our
international contacts and I'm
really looking forward to the results of this
cooperation and being
able to be part of it as a Berliner. Thank you very much, that's
exactly where we're coming now  For the
official part, we have a free
choice of pens here, as I see, I would
like to ask Jörg Urs and Thilo to come along,
a bit exciting, let's
start the food
revolution between our two
cities,
something to drink actually,
so we have the wine of science
with us, okay,
exactly, so I  I would say that there is
a round of applause for the partnership.
I will say that we are all looking forward to
seeing what
can thrive and grow in this breeding ground and what we
noticed, despite all the innovation and
all the changes, what remains the same
is that we sign partnerships
on paper  Donations and what we
do is unofficially celebrate the
partnerships by toasting together
and I would like to
warmly invite you all to come to us to
the exhibit down to the dinosaurs, let
's toast together,
eat and drink something together around the table
and enjoy and thank you very much
for being here today
[applause]